some top democrats finally addressing
the new scandal surrounding new york
governor andrew cuomo
he is facing calls for a second
investigation after a former top aide
accused him of sexual harassment
including unwanted touching and kissing
it's a big story but many in the media
are avoiding it check that out there the
broadcast network
cnn and msnbc did not cover the
allegations last night
and cnn spent about 40 seconds on it
today
and we are still waiting to hear from
these prominent democrats who championed
the metoo movement as for governor cuomo
he is denying the allegation but now
some of his old comments they're coming
back to haunt him
back in 2018 excuse me
cuomo demanded that brett kavanaugh take
a lie detector test
and also he took a big swipe at the now
supreme court justice take a look at
this
there is a disrespect for women
that this administration chronically
exemplifies after the metoo movement
they did absolutely nothing when it came
to sexual harassment
uh they have always diminished the
charges
of women always consistent
greg i always kind of feel bad for brett
kavanaugh that anytime a prominent
democrat is accused of sexual harassment
we have to say
well look what you did to brett
kavanaugh even though those allegations
were never even proven
even one of the accusations wasn't even
clear if he
ever even met the person yeah but that's
where we are
um your take on this well uh obviously
andrew
can make a pass and then get a pass the
real victim here dana
let's be honest chris cuomo's producers
they are
quickly running out of stories that cc
and the muscle factory are allowed to
cover
uh so i thought i would help cece
out and pitch some stories to his uh
producers
that chris could actually cover uh
number one dana the facts behind tiger
woods
accident was it putin and q working
together that made him crash
a four-hour expose starring carl
bernstein
who believes this is worse than water
than watergate yes and then number two
another pitch uh violence rioting and
arson
why it never happened last year except
for
one day in dc and that's a six-hour
report
and then number three the police
brutality epidemic
how it swept across america except one
day in january
when the police were heroes and then the
final one
i really did get covered seriously i did
and i never left the house
so those are some stories for uh cc and
the muscle factory
well if they're having their meeting
right now they'll take that under
advisement indeed
um kennedy um alexandria ocasio-cortez
of course she's given these uh
establishment democrats in new york new
york a little bit of trouble
she did make some comments about this
today she said that the allegations
against cuomo are extraordinarily
serious and deserve to be heard but she
also calls for due process from the
state legislature
once we actually get to the bottom of
the situation we can figure out what
accountability looks like
um so that's her take on it due process
is something that
i guess should happen here what do you
say yeah and there are other
democrat lawmakers in new york who are
saying the same thing
but but they're not the ones who are
making the blanket pronouncements
i believe all women where is kirsten
gillibrand she's a senator from new york
she is the one who wrote the playbook on
how to properly respond to allegations
of sexual harassment and sexual
assaults and the the presupposition
is if someone comes forward with the
claim you believe them you give weight
to that claim and andrew cuomo in that
hypocritical
clip right there he was talking about
the trump administration doing nothing
for the metoo movement
and denigrating women whereas his staff
was doing the exact same thing with
lindsay boylan yesterday
they were making her out to be a liar
and they were all trying to
discredit what she was saying and they
were all very guilty of the thing that
andrew cuomo was so
forcefully speaking against just a few
years ago
so he's he's in a lot deeper trouble
than uh
these major networks will give him
credit for
and they should be a lot more honest
with their coverage of this
one andrew cuomo suggested that brett
kavanaugh should take a lie detector
test
should should he take a lie detector
test
you know i don't see that this is
analogous i mean clearly brett kavanaugh
was in the midst of hearings it was very
time sensitive it was
being pressed at the moment so
everything had to be done in a very
condensed fashion dana but you know i i
don't
that's what he thinks would help him
politically go for it
i think you know we've been talking
about the cuomo nursing home scandal
and by the way i've seen this sex
scandal all over i i it's in all the
papers
but what strikes me is i think that you
know on second thought this may be
bigger and more damage to him
to him politically than the nursing home
scandal why do i say that because i
think if in the next 24 to 72 hours
other women come forward with similar
charges
i think at that point then it really
breaks loose on it
on on governor cuomo and you're going to
see not only
you know you're going to see not only
aoc but i think you're going to see
other democratic women
then begin to take a side i think that's
when the
the tides or the winds begin to shift i
want to just say
i don't think sexual assault should be a
partisan affair though but the key to
this
it seems to me is if you look at
kavanaugh if you look at cuomo the big
difference is the time frame and that's
why i say
the next two or three days could be
absolutely critical for what happens to
his approval numbers yeah the time frame
because kavanaugh was in high school
and cuomo was the governor
yeah i think he was up for a lifetime
appointment and he she actually did work
for him for example julie
uh was it swetnick was that her name
like there was no
proof that they ever actually even met
and yet that allegation got dragged up
one side and down the other